basically Twitter and Google
representatives will testify on Capitol
Hill today about Russian election
meddling Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
with what we expect to learn about that
Nancy good morning good morning well we
are going to learn that a Russian
Internet firm essentially at rolling
farm had a much wider reach than
initially believed Facebook is going to
tell senators that 29 million of its
users directly received Russian content
we're talking about ads and fake news
but then it gets worse they unknowingly
shared that material and re shared it
and as a result Facebook is going to
tell senators today that up to 126
million US users may have viewed that
material within a two-and-a-half year
time frame now Facebook executives will
note that this is still a tiny fraction
of what people see in their news feeds
every day but Twitter is going to
testify as well today and reveal that it
found more than 2,700 accounts linked to
that same Russian trolling farm twitter
says that those accounts have all been
suspended and that it is taking steps to
prevent future ones from being created
now Twitter Facebook and Google are
really going through the wringer here on
Capitol Hill over the next two days
they're testifying before three separate
committees they were initially slammed
by members of Congress for not
understanding the scope of this problem
but now senators say Nora that they feel
that the companies have gotten a handle
of it and that they truly want to figure
out ways to protect their users a big
day on Capitol Hill Nancy thank you